[Música]
seguimos con más en nayib bukele cumple
este primero de junio cuatro años como
presidente del Salvador en este tiempo
se ha convertido en un líder polémico en
la región mientras que sus porcentajes
de aprobación dentro del país superan el
90% su enfoque principal ha sido
combatir las pandillas y ha logrado una
disminución de los asesinatos pero del
otro lado el estado de excepción que
impulsó para que fuera de tres meses ya
cumplió más de un año y sigue vigente ha
tenido además fuertes enfrentamientos
con el legislativo y con la justicia
hablamos de este tema con Ruth López
quien es la jefa jurídica de
anticorrupción y Justicia de Cristo
Además ella también es experta en temas
electorales Muchísimas gracias Ruth y
bienvenida directo América Muchísimas
gracias Ángela Es un placer estar con
ustedes vamos a comenzar con la primera
pregunta sobre el balance general es que
usted hace de estos cuatro años de
gobierno de bukele
bueno en primer lugar el gobierno de
bukele se ha caracterizado por carecer
de políticas públicas Pero además tiene
por Eje digamos cuatro elementos el
primero es el uso de la propaganda con
una fuerte tendencia a la manipulación
de la información es decir No solo es el
uso de los recursos públicos para el
posicionamiento de sus ideas sino
también la manipulación de la
información donde tiene por centro la
falta de información y la falta de
acceso a la información pública en el
país anulando así uno de los Derechos
esenciales de la comunicación para la
ciudadanía y por supuesto a través de
las cuales ejerce la libertad de
expresión otro elemento muy importante
dentro del gobierno es la opacidad es
decir y siendo la opacidad una puerta
enorme grande para la corrupción ya ha
habido muchos escándalos de corrupción
durante el gobierno y tanto fue así que
bukele que dio origen a la psiquias Pues
también aniquiló otro elemento que
también debo debemos tener en cuenta es
la anulación del sistema de control en
El Salvador a partir de la Asunción de
bukele y posteriormente de una asamblea
legislativa totalmente dominada Pues hay
una cooptación de las instituciones de
control donde no hay una independencia
de las instituciones para poder realizar
realmente su función de rendición de
cuenta la excepcionalidad se ha
convertido en la normalidad de los 48
meses que lleva bukele gobernando más de
la mitad son en bajo régimen de
excepción o en un caso por un régimen de
salud y en otro caso por la seguridad es
decir hay una Clara tendencia
al abuso de los poderes de emergencia
absolutamente sobre eso quiero hacerle
mi siguiente pregunta pero lo que nos
queda claro es que sí hay
definitivamente un control de la
narrativa del país desde el ejecutivo Y
si eso es fiel a la realidad o no pues
solamente la historia nos podrá decir
cuando uno enfrenta esto estas críticas
contra una realidad de un 90% de
aprobación en el país pero bueno pasemos
a hablar de este tema que usted estaba
cerrando marzo del 2022 la asamblea
nacional aprueba un régimen de excepción
que ha sido promovido por el gobierno
con el argumento de combatir a las
pandillas una medida excepcional que no
solamente lleva ya más de un año sino
que ha sido criticada desde fuera por
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos como
las La Salvadoreña cristol por los
tratos denigrantes a las personas que
han sido arrestadas incluido castigos
que incluyen por ejemplo las descargas
eléctricas en Cuál es la situación de
Derechos Humanos que ustedes ven en el
país especialmente en este momento de
las personas privadas de la libertad es
sumamente grave son catorce meses de
suspensión de garantías y derechos en El
Salvador de manera consecutiva y ya no
solo se advierte como se ha seguido en
los primeros informes de estas
detenciones arbitrarias sin un debido
proceso sin que exista una investigación
previa etcétera sin que se le pueda
informar a la ciudadanía de las razones
por las cuales se produce la detención y
tener un abogado de de manera inmediata
sino que ahora se suman justamente
Ángela como ya refería el tema de las
torturas datos cruciales inhumanos Y
degradantes en el en el en el centro de
este sistema penitenciario y esto supone
también la inexistencia de un de
mecanismos de garantía por ejemplo hay
más de mil doscientos presentados en
durante el régimen de excepción a la
sala de lo constitucional y no da
respuesta a la ciudadanía de esto y así
todo el sistema judicial Hay una
cooptación que ya refería al inicio Pero
además no solo se ha identificado este
tipo de torturas sino también las
muertes en centros penales que ya son
suman 153 según investigación reciente
de cristal donde se evidencia que estas
personas han sufrido en su mayoría
graves torturas para y han por supuesto
terminado con su vida Bueno también otra
realidad que sucede ya mirando más el
tema regional es que estas políticas de
bukele han sido aclamadas sobre todo por
líderes de derecha latinoamericanos y
aquí quiero preguntarles si esta
realidad que se vive hoy en este país
podría replicarse a otros gobiernos Y
pues con una evidente alternancia
política que está por llegar en algunos
de los países Usted qué opina sobre esto
Sí claro de o sea bukele es un Dos punto
cero el autoritarismo y del
totalitarismo Incluso en nuestra América
Latina yo creo que una de los rasgos
también y precisamente por eso es que
creo que puede replicarse y que los
países tendrían que estar muy atentos es
porque el gobierno se caracteriza por
violar las formas por violar el derecho
y por tanto de ahí el enfrentamiento que
ha tenido es de manera permanente con
instituciones que en algún momento
fueron independientes es decir la
asamblea la asamblea legislativa cuando
no tenía el control el órgano judicial y
posteriormente estamos hablando del
enfrentamiento directo contra el
periodismo independiente y las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil el
problema de esto y el origen es el
deterioro del sistema de partidos que
deja de ser
un canal esencial para la representación
de la ciudadanía por lo tanto no es
descartable y además hemos visto como se
exacerba desde algunos países Incluso en
la oposición de algunos países y lo
contraponen a los líderes que en estos
momentos existen en los en algunos
países de latinoamérica de ahí que creo
que sí por supuesto es replicable y
habría que estar la ciudadanía
latinoamericana tendría que estar muy
pendiente de que esta ola eh autoritaria
No se termine implantando
definitivamente en la región y Una
última pregunta Ruth porque es muy grave
el panorama que se describe a nivel
institucional y también es muy grave el
panorama en derechos humanos con las
denuncias existentes cómo le queda usted
o qué sensación le da Cuál es ese sabor
en la boca de frente a estas denuncias
ver una aprobación del 90% en la
población que seguramente usted puede
percibir en la calle y en todos los
ámbitos en los que se desarrolla su vida
diaria
en primer lugar yo creo que ese 90% hay
que relativizarlo hay que relativizarlo
porque hay tres fenómenos importantes
uno es la implantación del mes del miedo
como mecanismo de control la gente no
está diciendo tampoco lo que piensa O
sea hay un régimen que se pueden llevar
a cualquiera por una denuncia anónima
Hay personas que se las han llevado por
sus denuncias en redes sociales y yo
creo que hay que tener en cuenta esto
dos la ciudadanía en estos momentos y de
alguna manera Hay una satisfacción por
la digamos por la disminución de los
homicidios también está basada por el
ocultamiento de la información decir los
salvadoreños no son totalmente libres en
Al momento de tomar una decisión porque
no carecen de la información necesaria
para eso y en un tercer elemento que
también es necesario tener en cuenta es
que toda esta población al final no se
expresa definitivamente en los procesos
electorales entonces hay que relativizar
ese noventa por ciento sin embargo más
que un sabor de boca es una realidad el
nivel de manipulación que tiene el
gobierno al mejor estilo de Evans creo
que hay que tenerlo en cuenta y por
supuesto el control de la narrativa y de
los medios nacionales y además de toda
esa plataforma en redes sociales de las
cual se ha logrado hacer pues mire los
ya nos quedamos sin tiempo pero le
agradezco mucho por poner su opinión
sobre la mesa una opinión informada
Además eso Ruth López jefa jurídica de
anticorrupción y Justicia de Cristo sal
que tenga un feliz día Buenos días
también el agradecimiento para nuestros
televidentes pero les pido que se queden
con nosotros hacemos una pequeña pausa
ya volvemos con más de directo a América
[Música]